you've talked about that the media
Slanders You by calling you an
anti-vaxxer
and you've said that you're not
anti-vaccine you're pro-safe vaccine
difficult question can you name any
vaccines that you think are good
um I think some of the live virus
vaccines are probably
uh so of earning more problems than
they're causing
there's no vaccine that is you know safe
and effective
yeah here's the problem
the polio vaccine contained a
um a virus called Simeon virus 40 sp40
it's it's one of the most carcinogenic
materials that it's not demand in fact
it's used Now by scientists around the
world to induce tumors and rats and
guinea pigs in labs
but it was in that vaccine 98 million
people who got that vaccine in my
generation got it and now you've had
this explosion
of soft tissue cancers in our generation
that kill many many many many many more
people than polio ever did so if you say
to me the you know the polio vaccine was
effective against polio I'm going to say
yes if I say if you said to me did it
kill more people than it did it ever
caused more deaths than ever heard I I
would say I don't know because we don't
have the data on that
so but let's talk well you know so we
kind of have to narrow in on is it
effective against the thing it's
supposed to fight well a lot of them are
let me give you an example
the most popular vaccine in the world is
the dtp vaccine tetanus and pertussis it
was used in this kind of introduced in
this country around 1980.
That vaccine caused so many injuries the
Elias which was the manufacturer was
said to the Reagan Administration we are
now paying twenty dollars in Downstream
liabilities for every dollar that we're
making in profits and we are getting out
of the business unless you give us
permanent immunity from liability
so the vaccine companies and were given
uh and and by the way Reagan said at
that time why don't you just make the
vaccine safe
and why is that because vaccines are
inherently unsafe they said unavoidably
unsafe you cannot make them safe
and so when Reagan wrote the Bill and
passed it the bill says and it's
Preamble is because vaccines are
unavoidably unsafe
and the brucewood's case which was the
Supreme Court case that uphold upheld
that bill
used that same language vaccines cannot
be made safe they're unavoidably unsafe
so this is what the law says now I just
want to finish this story because this
illustrates very well your your question
the dtp vaccine was discontinued in this
country and it was discontinued
in Europe because that so many kids were
being injured by it
however The Who and Bill Gates gives it
to 161 million African children every
year
and
um Bill Gates went to the Danish
government
and ask them to support this program
saying we've saved 30 million kids from
dying from diphtheria tetanus and
pertussis
the Danish government said can you show
us the data
and he couldn't so the Danish government
paid for a big study
with Novo Nordisk which is a
Scandinavian vaccine company
in West Africa and they went to West
Africa and they looked at the dpdp
vaccine for 30 years of data
and they they hire they retain the best
vaccine scientists in the world these
kind of deities of African vaccine
program Peter aab Sigrid Morgan said and
a bunch of others
and they looked at 30 years of data for
the dtp vaccine and they came back
and they were shocked by what they found
they found the vaccine was preventing
kids from getting diphtheria tetanus
appetizers but the girls who got that
vaccine were ten times more likely to
die over the next six months than than
children who didn't
why is that and they weren't dying from
anything anybody ever associated with
the vaccine they were dying of anemia
Hearts yeah malaria
sepsis
um and mainly pulmonary and respiratory
diseasement pneumonia
and it turns out this with the the
um
that this what the researchers found we
were all pro-vaccine by the way
they said that this vaccine is killing
more children
than pertussis prior to the introduction
of the vaccine and for 30 years nobody
ever noticed it the vaccine was
providing protection against those
Target illnesses but it had ruined the
children's immune systems and they could
not defend themselves against random
infections that were harmless to most
children but isn't that nearly
impossible to prove that link you can't
prove the link all you can do is for any
particular interest you can't
illness or after you can't prove the
link but you can show statistically that
there is that if you get that vaccine
you're more likely to die over the next
six months than if you don't and those
studies unfortunately are not done for
any other vaccines
so for every other medicine
in order to get approval from the FDA
you have to do a placebo-controlled
trial prior to licensure where you you
look at Health outcomes among a value
among an exposed group a group that gets
it and compare those to a similarly
situated group that gets a placebo
the only medical intervention that does
not receive that does not undergo
placebo-controlled trials prior to
license or vaccines not one of the 72
vaccines that are now mandated for our
children have ever gone they're gone
up placebo-controlled trial prior to
licensor so I should say that there's a
bunch on that point
I've heard from a bunch of folks that
disagree with you including Polio I mean
in the testing is a really important
point before licensure
placebo-controlled randomized trials
polio
uh received just that against the saline
Placebo control
so I it seems unclear to me I'm confused
why you say that that we they don't go
through that process it seems like a lot
a lot of them do
here's the thing
is that
um I was saying that for many years
because we couldn't find any yeah
and then in 2016 in March I met
president Trump ordered Dr fauci to meet
with me and Dr fauci
and Francis Collins and I said to them
during that meeting
you have been saying that I'm not
telling the truth when I said not one of
these has undergone a prior pre-licenser
let's see if a control
and Napoleon may have had one post
license like most of them haven't
the polio may have I don't know
but I said our question was prior to
license or do you ever test these
and for safety and by the way
I think the polio of axane
did undergo a saline Placebo trial
prior licensure but not for safety
only for efficacy
so I'm talking about safety trials now
I thought she told me that he was he
said I can't find one now he had a whole
tray of files there
he said I can't find that one now but
I'll send you one I said just for any
vaccines send me one for any of the 72
vaccines
he never did so we sued the HHS and
after a year of stonewalling us HHS came
back
and they gave us a letter saying we have
no previous things they've tried for any
of the 72 vaccines and that
the letter from HHS
which settled our lawsuit against them
because we had a foia lawsuit against
them
is posted on chd's website so anybody
can go look at it so if CHD if if
HHS had any study I assumed they would
have given it to us and they they can't
find one
well let me zoom out because a lot of
The Details Matter here pre-licensure
what does placebo-controlled mean so
this is
uh
this probably requires a a rigorous
analysis and actually at this point it
would be nice for me just to give this
shout out to
other people much smarter than me that
people should follow along with Robert F
Kennedy Jr
use their mind learn and think so one
really awesome Creator I really
recommend him is Dr Dan Wilson he hosts
the debunk the funk podcast
yellow who hosts this week in virology
brilliant guy I've had him on the
podcast somebody you've been battling
with is Paul offit interesting Twitter
interesting books people should read and
understand and read your books as well
and uh Eric Topo has a good Twitter and
good books and even Peter Hotes I'll ask
you about him and people should
because uh Paul often
um uh
published a sub stack recently debunking
I think my um
my uh discussion with
um with Joe Rogan and
um and we have published a debunk of his
debunking and you know so if you read
his stuff you should read both yeah you
should read uh
and I would love to debate any of these
guys
uh so Joe Rogan proposed just such a
debate which is quite
fascinating to see how much attention
and how much funding it garnered uh the
debate between you and Peter Hotes why
do you think uh Peter rejected the offer
I think it's I said you know again I'm
not going to look into his head
but what I will say is if you're a
scientist and you're making public
recommendations based upon what you say
is evidence-based science you ought to
be able to defend that it ought to be
evident defended in a public forum and
you ought to be able to defended against
you know all comers
and you know uh so I I you know if
you're a scientist Science is based on
is rooted in logic and reason and if you
can't use logic and reason to defend
your position
and by the way
I know almost all of the studies you
know I've written books on them and
we've made a big effort to assemble all
the studies on both sides
and so I'm prepared to talk about those
studies and I'm prepared to submit them
in advance you know and uh for each of
the points
and by the way I've done that with Peter
Hotes you know I've I've actually
because I had this um this kind of
informal debate with them
several years ago with them with a
referee at that time and we were
debating not only by phone but by email
and on those emails every point that he
would make I would cite science and he
could never come back with science he
could never come back with Publications
he would give Publications that had
nothing to do with for example if I'm
aerosol and vaccines Mercury based
vaccines he sent me one time
16 studies to to uh to rebut something
I'd said about thimerosol and not one of
those studies they were all about the
MMR vaccine which doesn't contain
thimerosol so it wasn't like a real
debate where you're
you know you're you're using reason and
isolating points and having a you know
irrational discourse I I don't think
that he
I don't blame him for not debating me
because I don't think he has the the
science
are there aspects of uh all the work
you've done in vaccines all the advocacy
you've done that you found out that you
were not correct on that you were wrong
on it that you've changed your mind on
yeah there are many times over a time
that I
you know I found that I've made mistakes
and we correct those mistakes you know I
run a big organization and I do a lot of
tweets you know I'm very careful for
example my Instagram
I was taken down from for misinformation
but there was no misinformation on my
Instagram everything that I decided on
Instagram was cited or sourced to a
government database or to peer-reviewed
signs
but for example the defender which was
our
our organizations
uh newsletter we summarize scientific
reports all the time that's one of the
things the services that we provide
so we watched the you know PubMed and we
watched the peer-reviewed Publications
and we summarize them when they come out
we have made mistakes when we make
mistake we are rigorous about
acknowledging it apologizing for it and
changing it that's what we do I think we
have one of the most robust fact
checking operations anywhere in
journalism today
we actually do real science and you know
there listen I've put up on my Twitter
account and I there's there's numerous
times that I've made mistakes on Twitter
and I apologize for it
and people say to me you know oh that's
weird I've never seen anybody apologize
on Twitter but I think it's really
important
at the only of course human beings make
mistakes my book is you know 230 or 40
50 000 words
there's gonna be a mistake in there but
you know what I say at the beginning of
the book if you see a mistake in here
please notify me I give a way that
people can notify me
and if somebody points out a mistake I'm
going to change it I'm not going to dig
my feet in and say you know I'm not
going to acknowledge this
so some of the things we've been talking
about you've you've been uh an outspoken
contrarian and some very controversial
topics
uh this has garnered
some Fame and recognition in part for
being attacked and standing strong
against those attacks if I may say for
being a martyr do you worry about the
this drug of martyrdom that might Cloud
your judgment first of all yeah I don't
consider myself a moderator and I've
never considered myself a victim I make
choices about my life and I you know and
I'm I'm content with those choices and
peaceful with them
I'm not trying to be a martyr or a hero
or anything else I'm doing what I think
is right because I want to be peaceful
inside of myself
um but I the only guard I have is just
is you know fact-based reality
if you show me a scientific study
that shows that I'm wrong for example if
you come back and say look Bobby
here's a polio
um here's a safety study on polio that
was done pre-licensure and used a real
saline solution I'm going to put that on
my Twitter and I'm going to say I was
wrong
there is one out there so you know but
that's all I can do